SKIP INTO 1:33 FOR VIDEO
Okay, before this video begins it's time for me to flex on you. I have the stream deck mini everyone
very nice for those you don't know this is basically like a
Shortcut hotkey function it's super convenient. If you're a youtuber or a streamer Elgato always making my life easier
So right now for example, I have this button that lets me record with OBS
I literally just press this and I'm no one recording very nice. You can also turn it into a sound board
I only have one bed
Brad Brad Brad
You can basically do anything it's very nice also
Obviously control music there's so many different things you can do with this. Send tweets out right away
I have all my most commonly used apps as hot keys and
Websites as well. I should not go into main there right now
They are super easy to set up so many different functions. This thing is great
I highly recommend checking it out, and that's it. Check out the video now. Bye
Okay
Don't they look slick so cool Elgato just keeps on popping out like the best products
I would 100% buying these even if I weren't sponsored with them
They're really good obviously and they come with a clamp in the stand
So you can adjust them change the height change the direction flop them on your desk and bam
You got good lighting in your videos. That's right. Pretty good
Plus you'll save a lot of money if you go with another brand that I used to have for this
You're just gonna pay way more for no reason. Thank you Adam for sponsoring this video
Am I interrupting something here look under my skirt. I can't just lift it up boy here
You know some stuff you just shouldn't
revisit
For obvious reasons. Nothing has improved Hey put it on put it on me. Bongo. Cat. Come on
Come on give it to me put it on put it on
Oh
Okay, the reason I'm playing this
Shut up, please. Hey, what up pokemon? How you doing?
Anyone who places that isn't brain dead?
No, are you
No
No, no no, no
Okay good to meet you
Yes, ah
Oh
Hey, hey, we got younger sis. There it is jungle jungle. So let me become
I'm Chung goes. Oh my god, this changes everything
Oh, well, you sound like a 12 year old
Jungle get it right, please
never
I'm solid ass, please guys, he's got unsubscribe
No, I did I'm banning your band, I'm sorry
No, there's no apology am I interrupting something here my skirt I can't just lift it up boy here
Is a penis run banished run?
Wait wait, you wanna see my penis? Oh hell yeah
Yes, yes sure, of course
Don't report me why?
Writer write
Jesus Christ a good eventually pizza just abusers its
pizza kind
What's going on spider main?
Not much, not much
Not much. That's cool. Are you doing no, I'm sorry. I don't don't mean to interrupt keep keep doing what you're doing
You got a great ass spider-man
You okay there buddy you all right there, buddy
A big chunk is Jesus Christ. You never heard of me my
It's the real one you're going then big chuckles
You're probably my name I gotta stay hidden two-time ninja I can't just not ninja
No, no, I get that a lot it's a common misconception. Okay, people just say
I don't know the ins and outs
Autism has become an epidemic
Who said that? Okay, it's time. Don't worry plastic surgery can do wonders
You'll I'm sure that you're right. I'm about to do it. You're about to do plastic surgery
Yes. Oh
My god, I'm here blue now. Oh, okay. Great. You're an anime thought like everyone else. Great. Hey, look, there's another one. I
Never played I Hey whoa, whoa
Ha-ah hey. Hey, Ukraine, I do
Got it Oh what how
This bullet I hit it right in the ass Oh
Get
Hello guys, what up, bro? Oh
Sorry, hey. Hey, what are you looking at you go in the corner? You're fine
Sit down sit down. All right. Are you the murderer? No, say that again. Are you the murderer?
No, cuz I would have killed you already. Oh, yeah, you would have how
Because because there's a knife right here
I can't don't shoot the gun. Shoot. I'm not shooting anybody. Ah
Caterham ace I guess they never miss, huh?
Alright, let's freakin do this guy's everyone have fun and good luck. Okay Oh,
Oh
It's CaptainSparklez my favorite minecrafter
Hey, man, what's up? What's up?
What's up, Oh, it's PewDiePie
Hell, yeah. Bye everyone
Yeah, oh oh yeah, that's epic I am love PewDiePie. Hey, where's Peter fine, where did Peter by go? Oh
Oh, oh no
Not 35
Feet if I put on the gun PewDiePie put down the gun PewDiePie, don't do it
I gotta getta brofist from my time. Come on my hands
Come on sing sing bases on your please, okay
Now they
Don't like it if I now you are you sound like
The bridge and then you whinnies
Don't bully paid a pyre to do it
PewDiePie, hey brah, but
We're gonna dive to stay here watch out for the barrels brah. Hey no a
Petabyte. Hit me up with a broad face, bro
Yeah, yeah
Be careful in there you
Kidding me are you kidding me? You kidding me. It sounds like
How dare you oh my god, no one touches you
You are the real
That's the real Phoenix
Is a real pretty spine. There's the real pretty pike place your hand if you bring it back
Who's the real 35? I took my guy?
You
Tell me
What happened
We're gonna break the sub-game Jesus Christ. Yeah, we broke it great. You know, we broke the Sarah
All right, bro, it's been a pleasure
But I'm out hope you guys enjoyed that video smash like if you did
I also want to let you guys know we are accepting pre-orders
For Itsuki the last collection for the final time. Okay, it will be one more pre-order and then it's gone forever
I think at least so only today last chance check out Sookie link in description. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye